The Joe Rogan Experience but but fat is
fat and and it's not it's just not
healthy even if you find it beautiful or
sexy or whatever you want it it's just
science it's bad for literally every
part of your health from how you poop to
your eyesight there's nothing that
obesity doesn't affect negatively you
know who doesn't get any of that uh body
positivity [__] though is men
nobody gives a [__] about men if a
matter of fact you're just fat that's
like when James Corden tried that [__]
with you yes yes it was such an obvious
Ploy oh you're hurting my feelings oh
yes thought shaming like first of all
that guy's fat from food he's not like
oh my God he's got a genetic disorder
he's just that's not guys obviously not
working out and living living a good
life eating some nice food and a little
plump yeah an invisible interesting and
wow and interesting a year or so after
he made his big Crusade against me
um
he signed a big contract I think with
Weight Watchers
you know
it turned right around
um but even Weight Watchers is out of
style because now we we have we've given
up on the idea
uh that obesity is something that can be
contained uh by exercise and
diet it's now a disease
I mean these new uh drugs they have
ozempic yeah I was reading about ozempic
uh I didn't know this until recently
they have zero clue
why it works
they know that it works
just not why
this would bother me
a little you know it should that if
they're they're giving me something and
and they're like hey this new Miracle
pill just take it we're working on the
reason why it might do this to you but
until then just [__] it there's no
biological free lunch either I have
friends that are on that stuff and one
friend who just got off of it because he
was having some serious gastrointestinal
issues that are Apparently one of the
side effects it's not there's no free
lunch if you're taking an injection that
makes you less hungry something's going
on that's probably not good yes and
you're also losing a lot of connective
tissue bone mass and muscle mass uh my
good friend Peter attia did a study on
his patients he's a doctor did a study
on patients that took ozampic and one of
the things they found is they lost
weight but they gain fat they were
actually had a higher percentage of body
fat because they were primarily losing
muscle tissue and connective tissue they
were losing so much of that that even
though the they lost like 20 pounds they
actually went from like 15 body fat to
maybe 20 body fat or whatever the number
was but what I what I find the most
alarming is the way in just a matter of
a few years the group think
that this is a disease now now that
cannot be controlled by what for 50 100
a million years before this it was the
scientific consensus that of course you
can control it yeah with diet and
exercise just in a couple of years that
went out the window and you cannot read
you cannot find an article uh on the
front page or in the op-ed page of the
New York Times in the last couple of
years
that has any other belief than this one
that it is a disease it is not within a
person's control
so they're all in on a zenpic or
whatever else because we certainly can't
leave this to people themselves to
control it that's a giant sea change and
the way they sheep like just go right
in a row yeah
no dissent not one person standing up in
the paper of record to say wait a second
this can't really be the case I mean 50
years ago we look like a completely
different people yeah why is it in 50
years did we evolve in 50 years human
beings was cake not delicious 1969 I
think it was and yet some somehow people
resisted it well there's a lot of diet
changes for sure and I think one of the
things about the narrative there was
there was a lot of influence by
vested interests like you know I'm sure
you know about the 1950s I believe it
was where the uh sugar industry paid off
scientists of course to uh yeah to put
the blame on well saturated fat it
changed people's eating and corn yeah
corn corn they changed what the sugar
came from because they had too much corn
because they subsidized it yeah so let's
make sugar out of corn which is not
really what you should be making the
right I mean cane sugar is not great for
you either but it's bigger better than
corn you see the Obesity rates go up as
the as corn syrup but it's still within
someone's power to turn it down you're
not helpless there's plenty of people
out there that have done it too that you
can get examples from I mean especially
in this day and age with YouTube and
these social media influencers that have
lost a ton of weight some of those
people have gone on diets and lost a 150
pounds and they'll tell you how they did
it and you can get inspiration from them
it's not rocket science it's doable but
it's not easy and the idea of calling it
a disease it's interesting because we
kind of agree alcoholism is a disease
but it is similar because you are
addicted to food like people are
absolutely addicted to food especially
high fructose corn syrup products and
things where there's like you're getting
that Big Sugar Rush and the insulin
spikes and well they they
do this in the lab you know I mean they
have all these food companies thanks
all these food companies have
Labs where they go in and they test how
much fat and sugar and salt we can put
in this thing to make it as addictive as
possible you know they don't want you to
just eat one about Lays Potato you bet
you can't they want you to have the
whole bag and then start another bag
yeah